ELLIE POWERS: All right.
Hi, everybody.
Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
ELLIE POWERS: Good morning.
Good morning.
Wow, it's amazing
to see so many
people out in the morning.
And hello to you back there
who waved at me.
Thank you.
So I'm Ellie Powers.
I'm the Product Manager for
Google Play Developers, so
many of you guys here.
MILES BARR: Hi, I'm
Miles Barr.
I'm the Engineering Manager
for Apps in Google Play.
RICARDO GOVONI: Hello, I'm
Ricardo, Tech Lead for the
Google Play Developer Console.
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
And some of you saw us earlier
this week at I/O. And so what
we're going to be doing today
is to give you even more of
what we showed you.
So you'll get to see more
details on the new features we
announced, as well as a couple
more new things.
So let's go back in the
past for a second.
Last year, Android market,
do you remember that?
It was a recent memory.
And Google Play was brand new.
And all of you who publish apps
on Google Play were using
something that looks
like this.
This is the old Developer
Console.
I hope you've completely
forgotten about it.
But if you haven't, it looked
a little bit like a
web form from 1999.
And so Miles and I came on the
stage at I/O last year and
said, guys, we've totally
heard you.
Your businesses are
really taking off.
And you need something that's
really going to scale.
You need some professional tools
to support all the great
things that you're doing now.
And we said, don't worry.
We've got your back.
We've been working on
something great.
It's the new Developer
Console.
So back in London, where we're
all based, we were excited to
see your response.
You started sending
us thousands
of pieces of feedback.
It just all started
pouring in.
And many of you may
be wondering.
I sent in that feedback.
And then what happened?
Did anyone read it?
Did it just go into a hole?
And so I can actually tell
you, rest assured.
Your feedback was read.
And I know that because I
actually read every single
piece of feedback that you sent
in, by the feedback link
at the top of the new
Developer Console.
And so I can tell you that
actually we were delighted to
see that the number one piece of
feedback that came in was,
hey guys, this new developer
console, it's a lot better
than the old one.
And so we were relieved that at
least we were going in the
right direction.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We were absolutely delighted to
see that positive response.
But also what started
coming in was a
bunch of feature requests.
Hey, this is great.
But could you also do--
how about this?
I also need that.
You really should
be doing more.
And we said, absolutely, we
totally agree with that.
And so that's why we've
been rolling out
a ton of new features.
So what we're going to do today
for you here, with some
great demos, is to show
you how Google
Play is evolving rapidly.
We're rapidly moving to bring
you tons of new features that
are going to grow with your
business and help you support
Google Play's enormous audience
around the world.
So let's walk through what
we're going to do today.
So again, we're going to be
going into more detail on what
you've already seen and
also seeing new stuff.
We're going to be going through
three different areas.
We have publishing your app your
way on Google Play, how
you can take control of
publishing in our store,
connecting directly
with customers.
Secondly, we're going to be
talking about optimizing your
app, how we're giving you more
data so that you can go deeper
into how people are using
your app and improve it.
And then, finally, how you can
expand your app globally to
take advantage of Google Play's
global footprint and
reach more audiences
in new markets,
expanding your business.
So without any more ado,
we're going to
look at cool new stuff.
And Miles Barr is going to
take us through that.
MILES BARR: Thanks, Ellie.
I want to start today by talking
about how Google Play
keeps you in control of
publishing your app.
Our philosophy has always been,
"put no barriers between
you and your users."
Meaning, when you have a new
version of your app ready, you
can push it out to everyone
at the same time.
This can be very daunting
though, as anyone who's pushed
a new app with a serious
bug knows.
So we figured we
can do better.
I was happy to announce on
Wednesday that we launched a
beta testing and staged rollout
feature in Google Play.
This means you can start testing
your new version of
your app with a small group of
alpha testers, and when it's
ready, move on to a larger
group of beta testers.
And once you're comfortable your
app is ready for prime
time, you can roll out
in stages to the rest
of your user base.
This means you can keep your
startup's new app under wraps.
You can try out a major new UI
with just your power users.
Or you could even give a
preview to the press.
And why is this important?
Because we want to ensure that
your users are always happy
with your app.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
Here we are in the developer
console.
As you can see, there are two
new tabs, Alpha Testing and
Beta Testing.
These are essentially
the same thing.
They're two targeted groups,
that allows you to send a
version of your app to a
specific set of users.
If the user is in both tests,
they'll receive the alpha one.
At Google, our philosophy
is to test our
software early and often.
So whenever a build is ready,
we send it to our team.
So they can try it out.
So let's switch to the Alpha.
And we'll do the same here.
So first, we got a new APK.
And what we're going to
do is, we're going
to target our team.
And we're going to do this
with a mailing list.
So Ricardo is entering our
team mailing list here.
Now when you target a user for
a beta test or an alpha test,
they're not automatically
opted in.
For them to receive the version,
they need to go to
this link here and opt-in
to the test.
And this is available on the
web and on the phone.
And it explains to your users
what being a tester is.
And they can opt-in.
And if at any point, they want
to opt-out of the test, they
can come back to the same page,
opt-out, and uninstall
the test version of your app.
Now, beta tests and alpha
tests are private.
What this means is, until a
user opts-in to your test,
they'll see no details about
the app on the Play Store.
Similarly, we don't
allow reviews
of pre-release versions.
So none of the details of
your new app will leak.
We recommend using a mailing
list or Google community to
talk your testers.
We do collect statistics and
crash report data on your test
versions, so you can track the
progress of how it's going.
So let's say the alpha
test is going great.
So we're going to
move it to beta.
And this time, we want to have
a wider set of testers.
So instead of a mailing
list, I'm going to
use a Google+ community.
This community is some of
our most engaged users.
They love our app.
They love testing early
versions and giving us
feedback on the new features.
So Ricardo is going to let the
group know that we've got a
new beta test ready.
And they can opt-in.
Now when setting up a beta test,
it's important to get a
good representation
of your users.
And by this, I mean make sure
that you've got a good mix of
devices, people who speak
different languages, and
people on different carriers.
You want to ensure your app
works for everyone, once you
publish it.
OK.
So we've got a lot of feedback
for our beta test.
We fixed some bugs.
And this latest version,
we're comfortable with.
So we want to get it
out to production.
I'm feeling pretty good about
it, because we've been through
so many rounds of testing.
But sometimes, a bug
does slip through.
And what happens when
you launch it?
It means you get a lot
of unhappy users
and one-star reviews.
So we're going to be on
the safe side here.
And we're going to do
a staged rollout.
So rather than choosing
everyone, we're going to start
with about 10% of our users.
At this point, users can
now review your app.
So you can see the feedback
of how it's doing.
And if there's a problem,
you can stop the
rollout, create a fix.
And then we'll push that fixed
version to that same original
10% of users.
RICARDO GOVONI: Shall we roll
it out to everybody?
MILES BARR: Hm?
RICARDO GOVONI: Shall we
do it to everybody?
MILES BARR: Yeah, let's
go to everyone.
All right.
And you can also use this
feature to control traffic to
your backends.
We know sometimes, when you
release a new version of your
app, the traffic patterns
differ.
So by just looking at 10%,
making sure you're backend
service can handle the load,
you could be sure once you
push it to everyone, your
app will work great.
OK.
Let's hear about how someone has
been using beta testing.
Wattpad is a great app, that
gives you access to over 10
million free books and
short stories.
They have been beta testing
since the beginning.
And they do this by having two
separate apps in the Play
Store, a beta version and
their main live one.
The beta version, they push
every single week and the live
one about once a month.
Each feature they add to their
app goes through three to four
rounds of beta testings.
So they get lots of feedback.
And they decide what makes the
cut and should go to the
monthly release.
A great example of this is the
new UI you see up here.
They recently changed
how users' books
appear in their library.
This is quite a big change.
So they wanted to see how
users would react to it.
Unsurprisingly, they found
that some users got it.
Some didn't There was
a bit of confusion.
So before they launched it, they
added a tutorial section,
explaining what the change was
and how to find your books.
This led to a seamless
roll out to the
rest of their users.
Well, they'd been beta
testing before we
launched our feature.
This meant that they had to
created two listings and also
manage their testers outside
of Google Play.
With the launch of today's
feature, you can retain one
store listing and also use
Google tools like Google
Groups and Google+ Communities,
to manage your testers.
Wattpad has a huge beta-testing
community, 25,000 users.
But they've told us that they've
seen benefits back
when they only had 10 users.
This gave them access to a wider
range of devices than
they had testing in-house.
It also meant they got early
feedback from real users.
So if you ever get a one-star
review again, you know haven't
been beta testing.
Now I want to talk to
you about tablets.
There are over 900 million
Android devices activated now.
And a growing part of
that is tablets.
On developer.android.com, we now
show you the proportions
of devices, by screen size
and screen density.
Tablet are the large and
extra large screens.
So you can get a good
idea of how many
tablets are out there.
Also on developer.android.com,
we've launched a tablet app
quality checklist.
This explains Google's criteria
of what makes a good
tablet app and gives you advice
on how to optimize your
app for tablets.
If you haven't seen this
already, please go to
developer.android.com
and check it out.
Also, in the developer
console, here in the
Optimization Tips section, we
automatically scan your app
against the checklist to
see how you're doing.
If there's anything which your
app doesn't meet, we explain
it and tell you how to fix it.
So it's important to follow
these tips, so you create a
great tablet experience
for your users.
Also, once you've created a
great new tablet UI, a nice
multi-pane, using the fragments
API, you want to
show it off.
So last month in the Play Store,
we gave you the ability
to upload tablet screenshots.
So you can show how your app
will look on a 7 inch and 10
inch tablet.
When a user goes the Play Store
on a tablet, they'll see
the tablet screenshots first.
And on a phone, they'll
see the phone ones.
On Wednesday, we announced that
the top lists on tablets
will be able to be filtered
down, so users will only see
those apps designed specifically
for tablets.
So make sure that you follow
all these guidelines.
So your app doesn't
get left behind.
So let's take a look at
a great tablet app.
I'm sure you've heard
of Evernote.
If you haven't, it's an app that
lets you collect notes,
record web page, everything,
and syncs
across all your devices.
Evernote has been creating a
tablet app ever since we
launched Honeycomb,
back in 2011.
They created a beautiful
multi-pane UI and spent a lot
of hard work on their
tablet experience.
It's all this hard work which
has kept them a consistent
Editor's Choice in
Google Play.
And it's not just
a hit with us.
It's also a hit with
their users.
As you can see here, their
second most popular devices is
a Nexus 7, a tablet.
Evernote has thought long and
hard about what makes a good
tablet experience.
If found on a phone, they user
can record a quick note or
maybe pull up a piece
of information.
But on a tablet, they spend a
lot more time organizing and
planning and getting
real work done.
Here's what their VP of
product had to say.
By focusing on creating a great
tablet experience, they
created more engaged users.
And these users have gone
on to become paid
subscribers of Evernote.
All right.
Now I want to talk about a
feature that's coming later
this summer.
A lot of you have told us you
want to give access to the
console to more people
within your company.
In fact, if you were in the
Fireside Chat yesterday, a lot
of you asked for finer
grade controls to
the Developer Console.
So late this summer, we're
releasing several new
permissions in the Play Store,
allowing you to control
exactly what each of
your users can do.
And these permissions
can also be set on a
per-application basis.
So if you've ever wanted to give
someone in your company
access to your stats but make
sure they don't mess around in
your APKs, you'll soon
be able to do that.
So please stay tuned.
Last year, here at I/O, we
announced a pilot to our Reply
to Reviews feature.
This allowed you, as a
developer, to reply directly
to your users.
We're happy to say, after lots
of rounds of testing and
tweaking, we've now made
available to every single
developer on Google Play.
It gives you a direct channel
to your users.
So if you haven't started using
this already, please
read up on our policies
and guidelines and
start replying now.
Now I'm going to tell you about
how one developer has
been using this feature.
textPlus is an app that let's
you chat with your friends all
around the world, through free
SMSs and cheaper calls.
textPlus has gone all-in
on replying to reviews.
Everyone in their team takes
part in this, from the
engineers, the product managers,
and of course, their
customer support team.
Every day, twice a day, they
look to see if they have any
new reviews and reply
directly to them.
By doing this, they've really
connected to their users and
find out what their biggest
pain points are.
For each negative review, they
try to turn around that user's
experience, by giving
them advice and
pointers to more help.
If they succeed, those users
typically change their review
to a positive one.
But they don't stop
just there.
For their positive reviews, the
five-star reviews, they
find these users are their
most engaged users, the
biggest advocates who tell other
people about the app.
They use the Reply to Review
feature to speak directly to
them, to get their opinions on
new features and what else
they want to see in this app.
By focusing on the user and
having this intensive customer
support, the newer versions of
textPlus have a higher average
rating in the Store, than the
previous versions did.
Here's what they had
to say about it.
They've used this direct line
to their users to prioritize
what features they
should focus on.
And now they have happier
users and higher
scores within the Store.
Now I'm going to hand over to
Ricardo, our tech lead, to
tell you more about data.
MILES BARR: Thanks, Miles.
Hello, everybody.
So Miles showed you how you can
have more control on the
way you deploy your app to your
users and how you present
it to them.
Now I want to shift your
attention to data.
I want to show you
how [INAUDIBLE]
developer console helps you make
informed decisions about
your app and your business and
helps you figure out what is
the next most important
thing to focus on.
Over the course of last year, we
expanded the amount of data
that we make available
in developer console.
I think you're familiar with
the standard metrics,
installs, and uninstalls per
user, per device, divided
across six different dimensions,
country, SDK
version, application version,
language, and more.
But in the past few months, we
rolled out a few more metrics.
And we announced a couple of
them a couple of days ago in
the keynote.
So let me focus on them
for a second.
One I want to talk about
now is, Rating Stats.
Rating Stats show you how the
User Star Rating for your
application changed over time.
This is the metric you want to
look at when you want to see
whether the new version of
your application you just
rolled out is getting the same
good user reviews, good user
satisfaction, compared to
the previous version.
We offer these in
two variants.
So you have the cumulative
rating.
This is the Overall Aggregated
Rating, over the lifetime of
your application.
This is good for the long-term
view, when you want to review
what you did historically in the
past and the decision that
you made at the time.
Another one that we offer is
the Daily Average Rating.
This is the aggregated overall
daily ratings, over the
lifetime of your app.
And this is good for the
short-term view, when you want
to spot problems early on.
I want to mention a couple
of cases where this is
particularly useful.
One is Reply to Reviews.
So you can use this metric to
identify segments if your user
base where customer satisfaction
is not as good as
you would expect.
And from that, you can then jump
to Reply to Reviews, as
Miles just described, and
provide dedicated customer
support exactly to
those users.
On the other side, it works the
other way around as well.
If you're spending a lot of time
doing customer support
and offering replies to your
users, then you might want to
use this metric to verify the
effectiveness of what you've
done and see that you're
actually achieving the results
the you were expecting.
Another feature in which this
is particularly useful is
staged rollouts.
Unlike alpha and beta, where a
user cannot leave reviews or
ratings, during a staged
rollout, users will be able to
rate and review your app.
And that means that, when you
are at 5% of a stage rollout
of you brand new application out
there, you are on the edge
of your chair.
You want to make sure
everything is fine.
You may want to use this
metric to see whether
everything is doing as
well as you expect.
In this example, we rolled
out a new version of our
application in mid-April,
the orange line.
But it never really caught up
with the baseline, which is
the green line.
And so this is maybe the point
where you want the pause your
staged rollout and decide
what to do.
Like all the other metrics that
we have, if the breakdown
by the top ten values, like
the top 10 countries
[INAUDIBLE]
is not enough, obviously, you
can always export as a CSV.
And you get the full
data payload.
So you can integrate
it with your tools.
Another thing that you want to
talk about is filtering crash
reports, because we now allow
you to filter crash reports by
application version,
since a few weeks.
Again, now that we have beta
testing and staged rollouts,
this is extremely useful.
Because it means that you can
look at the crash reports that
are coming only from your
alpha version--
maybe it's a little bit
more crashing--
and then decide what to do.
During a staged rollout
as well, we keep
collecting crash reports.
And so you can see and decide
what to do for your staged
roll out, whether to pause it
or continue it, based on the
amount of crashes that
you're getting.
So now everything is fine.
Users are happy.
You're not getting any crashed,
unicorns and rainbows
all over the place.
It's time to talk about money.
I want to talk about a new
page that we launched on
Wednesday, which is
Revenue Charts.
I always find it a bit annoying
that, just to figure
out how much money you made
yesterday, you had to go to
the Developer Console, download
the CSV report, put
it in a graph in the spreadsheet
program, aggregate
everything, just to see how much
money you made yesterday.
And I think that was
just nonsense.
And so we decided to fix it.
And starting Wednesday, you
have this new page.
We show you how the revenue
for your app changed over
time, aggregated daily.
You can divide it or inspect it
by country and by source of
revenue, say, by applications
revenue generated from
application sales, in-app
products, or subscriptions.
I think this is great to get
an overview of how your
application is doing
at a glance.
You can come her every day,
look at how much money you
made yesterday.
And it lets you also do
some sort of analysis.
You can look at whether you
are ahead of you company
targets or not and whether some
countries are performing
as well as you would expect.
But I also know that many of
you want to integrate this
data with their own custom
financial reporting tools and
data pipelines.
So another thing that we're
doing in the coming few weeks
is that all of financial
reporting from the Google Play
Developer Console will
be available in
Google Cloud Storage.
And what that means is that,
by using the utilities
provided by Google Cloud
Storage, like GSU2, you will
be able to have programmatic
access to your financial
reports and to your
financial data.
So you can integrate it with
your own date pipelines.
The other benefit of this is
that, thanks to the new
permission model, granular
permissions that Miles just
described, you will be able to
set up a dedicated account
that will only have access to
financial data and will all be
used for accessing
the financial
data in Cloud Storage.
And that account will not be
able to mess up with your APK
configuration or something.
So you can separate
roles there.
OK, let's talk about referral
tracking and usage.
So another think that we'd like
all of you to have is one
place, one single place, where
you can see all the data that
pertains and is about
your application.
And I know that many of you are
using Google Analytics to
track user engagement and user
interaction with your
application.
But so far, the experience
was fragmented.
You had to go to the Developer
Console to see device and
install metrics.
You had to go to Google
Analytics to see activity and
user engagement.
And soon, during the coming few
weeks, you will be able to
link together Google Analytics
and Google
Play Developer Console.
And what that means is, that
once linked together, book by
in Google Analytics, you
will have access to
additional new metrics.
In particular, you will be able
to see how many views,
downloads, and installs your
marketing campaigns triggered
on Google Play.
And this is really good, because
it gives you a better
view of the conversion funnel.
You can see more details about
how your users discover your
app and then went to install you
app, and then became daily
active users.
This integration
goes both ways.
And so you will have access to
engagement metrics, directly
from the Play Developer
Console.
So next to installs and other
metrics, you will also see
engagement, like number
of active users.
So a few more things about
optimization tips--
so Miles spent a few minutes
talking about how you can use
the Optimization Tips section
to learn whether your app is
well-designed for tablets,
whether it meets the Quality
Checklist requirements,
and et cetera.
But I have bigger plans for the
Optimization Tips section.
I want that to become the place
where you go to discover
personalized recommendation and
insights that are specific
to your app and your context.
So starting from a few days ago,
from Wednesday, you now
have additional tips present in
that section, what we call
the Localization Tips.
They help you how to reach a
broader audience and how to
expand your app to multiple
countries.
When you decide it's time to
go global, you have to do a
number of things.
You have to localize your APK.
You have to the localize
your store listings.
You may even want to consider
localizing your screenshots,
because for some markets,
that's really important.
And most importantly, you have
to decide which countries to
focus on first, where
should I go first.
So now, in the Optimization Tips
sections, you will get
these localization insights.
They will guide you
in the process.
They will tell you whether
you're missing anything.
Maybe you localized your APK,
but you forgot to localize
your listing.
And we'll also help you identify
your opportunities.
For example, we'll tell you,
you may have a lot of free
users from Russia.
Even though you never localize
you app there, that's a great
opportunity that you should go
into, which brings me to the
next topic, which is reaching
Play's global audience.
When you decide to go global,
that first and most important
thing to want to do is localize
you application contents.
And many developers are
already doing that and
expanding into new markets.
And as non-native English
speaker, as you may have
guessed from my funny
accent, I'm Italian.
I think one of the most
important things is to make
sure that your app is available
to as many users in
as many countries in as many
languages as possible, but
still providing the same
high-quality experience that
you would provide to users that
speak your own language.
And we announced on Wednesday
that now, from the Google Play
Developer Console, you have
access to professional
translations in collaboration
with the Google Translation
Manager Team.
Let me show you how
this works.
So in the APK screen, at the
very bottom, there is a new
section which is called the App
Translation Service, that
you can use to start to
request a professional
translation.
Just click the button.
It starts a wizard that will
guide you through the process.
You pick a project name.
That is just for your
convenience.
You may have multiple projects
going on at the same time.
Pick the language you're
translating from.
You then upload the strings.
If you're using the Android
Developer Tools, you can use
that directly from the
Eclipse Plugin.
Otherwise, you can just
upload the XML files.
Once that's done, you wait.
There you go.
You pick the languages you
want to translate into.
I'm going to pick Japanese and
Korean. there are just two
markets that you cannot
be outside of.
You pick the service level.
The service level basically
decides how many users, how
many people are actually looking
at your strings and
contributing to the translation,
in the
translation company you pick.
You get an idea of the price.
You choose the translation
company you want to use.
You get an indication of how
long it's going to take and
how much it's going to cost.
Obviously, the cost of the
translation depends on how
many words you have in
your strings file.
And then, you get a confirmation
page, where you
can reorder and get started
with your translation.
The moment you confirm that.
The translation company will
start right away translating
your strings.
And from the Developer Console,
you will be able to
check progress.
You will be able to see how far
the translation company is
in processing all
your content.
While they're doing their work,
you will be able to
communicate with them, answer
any questions that might
arise, troubleshooting,
these kind of things.
And then, once all the
strings are done, you
will be able too--
again, from the Developer
Console--
download them, put them
into your APK, pack
everything, and publish.
And this feature is rolling out
in private beta, just like
we did for the Developer Console
itself last year,
which means that if you go to
the APK page right now, you
will see a sign-up form,
where you can leave all
your contact details.
And then, we'll shortly start
rolling this out to everybody.
I want to reinforce again the
importance of reaching a
global audience.
I want to speak for a few
seconds about Gameloft.
So I think all of you know
who Gameloft is.
They are a very successful
games company.
They are based in Europe.
They realized very early the
importance of targeting
multiple languages and
multiple locales.
They're currently available to
12 languages, English, German,
Italian, French, Chinese,
Japanese, and a few other
European and Asian languages.
And they have two experiences
they want to share with you.
One is when they decided
to localize "Ice
Age Village" to Russian.
So "Ice Age Village" has a user
base of 10 million users.
And they discovered that 14%
those users are actually
Russian users.
That's the second biggest market
after English users.
Another case that the had is
when they decided to localize
"My Little Pony" to Turkish.
As part of a global application
update, they had a
Turkish localization.
And they discovered very
interesting figures.
So the number of active users
in Turkey jumped up by 95%,
compared to 20% to 25% they
did in other countries.
And that was thanks to the
presence of localized content,
rather than just a simple
application update.
The revenue jumped up
by 600% in Turkey.
And the revenue per
daily active users
jumped up by 300%.
And another tip that you might
want to use, that they took
advantage of--
they used local holidays and
other local knowledge to make
promotions and sales, like they
did, for example, for the
Chinese New Year.
So let me stress it
one more time.
Think global, always trying
to target a really global
audience in multiple countries
and multiple languages.
I hope that these features that
we just announced will
help yo do that easily.
And if you want to learn more,
there's a session at noon, I
think, which is Building Android
Apps for a Global
Audience, where you can learn
more how this translation
process works and the
details beyond that.
Having said that, let me
go back to that Ellie.
Thank you.
ELLIE POWERS: Thanks, Ricardo.
All right.
So today, we've given you an
overview of everything that
we're bringing you to try to
help you grow your businesses
across these three
different areas--
first, publishing your app,
having more control over it,
connecting directly with your
user base; secondly, gaining
insight into your users and what
they're doing with your
app; and then, expanding your
app to grow your user base
into new markets.
So because there was a lot of
stuff, we're going to give you
a quick summary of everything
that's new.
So first of all, we have, of
course, beta testing and
staged rollouts, which allows
you to get user feedback,
early on in the process
and respond to it.
Secondly, we're giving you
summaries and overviews of
user ratings and your revenue,
so that you can check those
stats at your fingertips
very easily.
Next, we're giving you
tablet-specific screenshots.
So you can show off your
awesome tablet layouts.
And if your app isn't designed
for tablets yet, we give you
optimization tips to help
you make it that way.
We're also helping you identify
how to localize your
app and where you should
go first, with new
localization tips.
We also announced that
everyone can
now reply to reviews.
But stay tuned, because
there's a lot
more coming this summer.
So we have three new areas where
you should watch for
some announcements
on the Android
Developers blog in the future.
First of all, we're going to be
having those extra access
controls, so you can grant
more people access to the
Developer Console without
getting worried.
We're also adding new Google
Analytics integration figures.
So these were the Campaign
Referral Tracking Flows, that
conversion funnel, and also
seeing your Google Analytics
usage data, directly in
the Developer Console.
And finally, if you're
interested in translating your
app with our new App Translation
Service, which is
being offered in partnership
with our Internationalization
Team, sign up today in the
Developer Console.
It's at the bottom of
the APK page, if
you're looking for it.
OK.
So as I said at the beginning,
everything that we're doing is
with you, Google Play
developers, in mind.
And we need to keep getting
your feedback, in order to
plan our next 12 months and even
farther in the future.
So we hope that you'll join
us for Office Hours today,
following this session.
We hope that you also rush right
back after that, because
at 12 o'clock, there's a very
important session on
monetization.
And everyone is looking for more
information about money.
If you're watching this session
online and you miss
the office hours, you want
to make sure that you're
following Android Developers
on Google+.
Because that's the best place to
go to see new announcements
about what's happening in the
world of Android development.
You can watch Hangouts.
We always post our blog
posts there as well.
And we go and look for your
feedback about what you're
looking to see on Google Play.
So that's it.
And the next thing we're
going to do now start
by taking some questions.
We have about eight
minutes left.
So if you'd like to come to the
microphone at the front.
Or I think there may be possibly
one there as well.
That would be great.
We'll alternate between
the two microphones.
All right, so you in the red hat
at the front, what would
you like to ask?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chuck Rebb, form
AWeber Communications.
I actually have two really
quick questions.
I had a lot more.
But I narrowed it down to two.
So with the new alpha-beta
production system for
launching a new version, is
there's still a concept of
draft APKs?
And if so, how does
that relate to
testing In-app Billing?
ELLIE POWERS: Great question.
MILES BARR: You want
to take this one?
RICARDO GOVONI: No, please.
MILES BARR: Yes.
ELLIE POWERS: Miles is going
to take this one.
MILES BARR: So when you go into
the App Advance mode part
of the tab, you can
upload draft APKs.
So that's still separate from
alpha and beta testing.
You can imagine the alpha and
beta tabs are exactly the same
as production.
And the drafts are shared across
all three sections.
Is that right?
RICARDO GOVONI: Yes.
Go ahead.
MILES BARR: So they will have
access to In-app Billing, for
testing purposes.
RICARDO GOVONI: So specific for
In-app Billing, I think we
still have a few improvements
to do.
But from the In-app Billings
handbooks that was announced,
in these days, you can both use
the Tester section in the
Developer Profile, to decide
testers that will have, for
example, access to full In-app
Billing experience, without
having to actually pay.
Or you can use beta testing
and then side-loading that
APK, for example or to
do fake purchases.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
And then, my other question was
about the staged rollouts
for the actual listing.
If you want to add some new
screenshots, new description,
things like that, if you're
doing a staged rollout, is
only the people who are getting
the update going to
see the new listing?
Or is everyone going
to see it?
RICARDO GOVONI: No.
At the moment, there's just
still one listing.
So you may want to pay attention
to that for the
moment, for the time being.
So if you put something in
your Store listing, for
example, a brand new feature,
and you're still rolled out
only to 5% of the users.
It may be you have to
communicate that publicly.
Maybe you want to say that we
are rolling out a new version.
And that's a feature that
you are getting.
And they will be getting
over the next few days.
AUDIENCE: So you say,
for the time being.
That makes me hopeful about
what's to come.
MILES BARR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ELLIE POWERS: We're always
looking for feedback. all
right, in the back, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
Manford Mosa.
I have an interest in automating
the whole process
of the deployment now, with
staging in the deployment.
Is there some sort of plan
towards being allowed to
integrate in a continuous
integration server, to
automatically, as part of the
nightly build with QA tests
that are automated, push it out
to a staged environment
automatically?
I mean, at the moment I'm
doing with Selenium.
But that's a hack.
So is there some sort of plan to
like have an API maybe, so
it could even be integrate
in build tools?
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, all right.
We've totally heard you.
This has been a super-popular
developer request.
Everyone has got their
own system.
And we're really excited with
the beta testing, that more
and more people want
to be pushing their
APKs, even more often.
So I guess we won't say too
much about the future.
But we definitely will say,
we've heard that.
We're thinking about it.
And as soon is we have anything
to share, we'll
definitely let you know.
But we definitely hear
you on that one.
That's a very common request
that we get.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So in the Play Store,
you guys added the
Design for Tablets feature.
Because you recognize that
phones and tablets are
fundamentally different
in their apps.
With more Smart Glass products
coming out, is that going to
be accessible to other
types of products?
And if one were to manufacture
such a product, how would they
engage with you guys to make
sure that feature would happen
and set the criteria and
all that kind of stuff?
ELLIE POWERS: All right.
MILES BARR: All right.
ELLIE POWERS: Take this one?
MILES BARR: It's a good one.
So right now, we're only
focusing on tablets.
But we're aware, within
our team, we've got--
our team and externally-- lots
of different form factors that
are coming out.
So when you think of things like
Google TV, it's something
we consider.
I think we want to wait for a
particular device class to
take off or begin to get
a foothold, before
we change the store.
But definitely, other
form packs are
something we'd consider.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the device distribution
of my app in the Play
Store dashboard.
So what I see with the top 10
devices, my app is doing good.
But what are the top 10 devices
on an aggregate level
in Play Store that
I don't know.
And it might be the case that
the top device in my app might
be the 15th global
stack ranking.
And I might be leaving a lot of
money on the table because
my app really doesn't do well
on the top devices in the
global ranking.
Is there any way I can get
access to that data?
MILES BARR: So the short
answer is no.
But the aim is that, you
shouldn't be focusing on
particular types of devices.
You should be making sure your
app works across all devices
on the same great experience.
So don't worry too much about
specific devices.
Try to use the beta
testing feature.
Try to reach more users on
different devices, to make
sure it works well.
If you're doing some really
cutting edge stuff, we've seen
some people really push
the boundaries of 3D.
And sometimes that
causes problems.
You can look at the Crash Report
section, particularly
to find out if there's a
problem device and how
best to fix on it.
But definitely don't try to
optimize your app for a
specific set of devices.
Just make sure it's a great
experience for everyone.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: John Coryat,
with the Radar Now!
USNaviguide--
I have some maybe APKs in my
Developer Console that are
years old and essentially
abandoned.
And now, with the rollout of the
beta feature, I'm going to
have all these beta versions
of our app stuck out there.
Is there going to be a feature
to archive or delete old and
abandoned APKs?
ELLIE POWERS: Yes, this is also
a very popular request.
I saw some applause
over there.
So it depends.
So right now, many of you may
not know this, but if you have
not published an app, you
can delete it today.
So if you go to the Developer
Console, on the right-hand
side, there's a little
gray button.
And you can select Delete.
AUDIENCE: Well, these
are like apps that--
ELLIE POWERS: I know.
If you've published them, I
totally hear you on that.
I see a lot of feedback.
It's definitely in the top 10
things we're seeing coming
into the feedback.
So we hear you on that.
I guess, with the alpha and
beta, just to be really clear,
those are in the same
store listing.
So it's not going to litter
up your app page anymore.
But we definitely hear folks who
are having apps that they
don't work on anymore.
And they kind of want
to hide that.
AUDIENCE: Well, I have
beta versions of
our apps for testing.
And now, we're want
to abandon those.
ELLIE POWERS: With different
package names.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ELLIE POWERS: OK, I see.
Yes, we've definitely
heard that.
I guess we're not announcing
any changes today, that are
happening there.
But we've definitely heard
that as a top 10 request.
RICARDO GOVONI: It's that just
something that you would like
to hide from the applications
list?
AUDIENCE: Yes, it would be OK if
we could just archive them,
so that they're not sticking
there right in our face, every
time we go in.
Sometimes also, it would be
good to order, be able to
order the list.
So that the ones that we're
using and that are popular at
the top, instead of--
I don't know exactly.
You might have it
alphabetically now or something.
RICARDO GOVONI: I think
it's alphabetically.
AUDIENCE: But archiving, just
archive, hide or something.
ELLIE POWERS: A lot of folks
have wanted to hide the
unpublished ones, once they're
not using it anymore.
So we definitely have
heard that one.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks
very much.
Oh, I love the comments
thing by the way.
I've had it for a year.
It's great.
ELLIE POWERS: Awesome.
I'm glad.
In the back--
AUDIENCE: My question is
about staged rollouts.
And specifically, how do you
determine which percentage of
users is it.
And is it the same percentage
of users each time?
Or is it different?
So when you release new versions
of the app, is it
always going to be that
same 10% that
you're going to be trying?
MILES BARR: So it's random
per staged rollout.
So by that, when you're rolling
out a new version, we
sort of have a different
random seed.
So it's jut select which 10%.
But we keep that seed during
that rollout process.
So if you don't want to push
that out to 100% and you want
to replace it with another APK,
those original 10% will
get the update.
AUDIENCE: You could have a 2.0
to everyone, a 2.1 to 10% and
then a 2.2 to a different 10%?
Is that possible?
MILES BARR: No, there's
only one staged
rollout at any time.
RICARDO GOVONI: So any time you
do a staged rollout, we
pick a different part
of the population.
So it's not the same guys
that get the same
testing APK each time.
But during a staged rollout,
if you decide that the
particular APK needs changing,
then you can change it.
And the same group of users
will receive that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
MILES BARR: And also, to
clarify, staged rollout is not
for testing.
RICARDO GOVONI: Yeah, sorry.
MILES BARR: Only staged rollout,
when you're ready for
everyone to get it.
ELLIE POWERS: All right, so it
looks like we basically have
five seconds left.
But don't worry.
I still see some folks wanting
to ask questions.
We're just going to head
back to Office Hours.
And don't forget that there's a
Monetization session in here
in an hour.